zum ersten mal seit seiner afghanistan
reise wieder hier bei uns im studio ist
unser reporter und bild vize paul
ronzheimer guten morgen pauluhn du warst
lange zeit in afghanistan die menschen
haben dort weiß gott andere sorgen hier
in deutschland sprechen wir gerade viel
über corona wie ist die situation
eigentlich dort vor ort wird der
überhaupt keiner wahrgenommen in
afghanistan vergisst man corona keiner
trägt eine maske niemand interessiert
und man hat auch nicht das gefühl
irgendwie das ist ein großes problem
darstellt ganz im gegenteil
ist es einfach nicht vorhanden und man
fragt sich wie es eigentlich möglich ist
wenn niemand eine maske trägt wenn
niemand irgendwie abstand hält und
trotzdem geht sind wir ganz genau wir
haben pro jahr die die bilder den dicht
gedrängten menschen gesehen wir sehen
dich hier auch das war an den
sogenannten freiheitstag
außerhalb von kabul
und und man fragt sich in der tat wie
kann das sein interessanterweise liegt
die sieben tage incidents in afghanistan
ohne irgendwelche schutzmaßnahmen auch
nicht viel höher als bei uns auch wenn
man das vielleicht nicht eins zu eins
vergleichen kann weil viele ja auch
verstreut auf dem land leben aber 67 ist
die aktuelle zahl in afghanistan bei
übrigens nur unter zwei prozent
geimpften und 62 ist die zahl bei uns
trotzdem hat
gesundheitsminister sparen jetzt erst
für das nächste frühjahr ein ende aller
maßnahmen angeordnet wer schon mal auf
das zitat wenn keine neue
virusvariante auftaucht sagt spahn in
einem interview gegen die eine impfung
nicht schützt dann haben wir die
pandemie im frühjahr überwunden wieder
ein harter corona winter da sehen wir
jetzt dass die tat also ich glaube dass
ein schlag ins gesicht all derjenigen
die gehofft haben dass endlich corona
vorbei ist das in deutschland ist
irgendeine chance gibt auf ein freedom
day denen es ja einen anderen ländern
vor drei monaten schon gegeben hat und
ich finde das ein skandal dass der
gesundheitsminister jetzt spricht das
vielleicht nächsten frühjahr ist möglich
sein soll dass wir nicht mehr über krone
reden und man bekommt so ein bisschen
das gefühl dass die regierung eine art
corona fete schade dass ich gar nicht
aufrufen wollen darüber zu sprechen weil
aus sparen sich das ein relativ
einfaches thema ist man muss immer
wieder sagen seid vorsichtig passt auf
macht dies nicht macht das nicht anstatt
darüber zu sprechen was freiheit
bedeutet und dass das große problem
glaube ich dass wir in deutschland
weiterhin darüber reden was wir für
maßnahmen haben und nicht darüber reden
dass wieder rauskommt dass wir in den
freedom day kommen wie das
großbritannien schon gemacht hat im juni
wir sehen dass unsere zahlen runter
gehen und trotzdem wird unsere politik
panik teilweise man muss sagen dass es
immer noch politiker gibt die sagen man
muss aufpassen man muss darauf setzen
dass die maßnahmen vielleicht nochmal
wiederkommen und ich glaube dass wir in
deutschland da sehr weit hinten sind im
vergleich zu anderen europäischen
staaten
[Musik]